welcome to this video my master s sk 99
z team let me check that sir go crochet
champion of green 1995 in chess yahwah
chess that's not a surprise that is a
chess champion well I could have been
championing I don't know throwing tree
trunks or anything okay we have the
right here ready gambit here I can take
the pawn and in some way maybe should
take the pawn let's see now there are
many ways now for black he can play
Bishop eat 697 night a 6 is not a move
that i know but i will try to get the
porn back with 93 f or to make sure it's
not easily supported oh maybe I could
have plain it3 immediately now that I
think of it now it's kind of its kind of
illogical to play a for when he has
played night a six man but it's not it's
not really a big deal
so it seems that he really wants to
wants to keep this pawn yeah I don't
mind if it takes em White's development
is simply excellent and I have ideas
with a quick b4 b5 this is a very
interesting gambit this this form of the
Reggie opening at term gives very very
interesting dynamic possibilities on the
queenside it's very often it's not like
the same structure as the bank or gambit
but it is so it is similar in nature
when you see the queenside pressure the
bishop on g2 and b4 b5 is coming inside
so it's very nice especially his night
on a six now is really misplaced I think
he's already regretting his opening at
least some moves of it yeah that's very
easy I don't know what you will have to
do is I mean this a mouse slip on did
you really not see that I don't know and
ok let's let's do a little bit of
analysis to show that um how dangerous
it is um I don't know where we're black
should go here maybe d 6 or it's
difficult I always get more tempe if he
goes here maybe with this idea if to
note that Bishop h3 is always answered
be right by night f4 and I can do this
which is already threatening stuff
something like that with b5 coming it's
dangerous on I can also yeah device but
before be five I have
excellent development yeah he has not
cancelled and i'm going to open up
business here very quickly Black is
under under some pressure maybe he
should try to somehow get back here with
the Queen but this runs into into more
tempe I know that he only has two nights
developed and I have everything out
that's really good compensation yeah I
don't know what's the small slip I don't
know yeah well I want to show it anyway
because of the interesting opening this
form of the Reggie is is quite quite
interesting to study one idea is that
here especially in this move order the
move Bishop g4 which is quite often
played as in fact not that great do 295
I mean black hand Oba should be six but
very often they do things like that
after which white has those tactical
ideas based on Queen a4 check it's quite
interesting um and after Bishop f5 White
has a huge range of choice he can do
this which is the traditional way to
play pressure rising b7 nowadays it has
been found out that knight c6 the
Apostle or the pawn sacrifice but still
it's an interesting line and wide also
can do castles or b3 many other things
so we have some additional options here
in the red team compared to when you
don't play a quick c4 yeah and the main
critical try is really the capture after
which white can go night a three or
castles after castles now as mentioned
black has a wide choice but there are
many interesting possibility cm-1 for
example is this one which is played
quite often yeah this this kind of
position trying to trying to capture
here and yeah it very often continues in
a funny fashion
they like that and our white can
sacrifice on c6 this this line has been
played up to the up to the highest level
also inserted with a 4 and a 5 which is
a little bit different yeah there are
many interesting complications so it's
an interesting opening to study for
white at least as an alternative I'm not
sure how good it is as a main weapon but
it's a very good alternative to have in
your repertoire alright I hope you
enjoyed this game versus medicine man
but catch some interesting contact
thanks for watching